heures et ciboure songer aux vacances
une nouvelle destination riche de
curiosité naturelle est en train de
s'ouvrir la libye il y a trois ans
encore le pays du colonel kadhafi était
hermétique
l'année dernière trois cent cinquante
mille personnes sont venues profiter du
désert et des oasis
en france la destination séduit de plus
en plus gilles marine et matthias second
envoyés spéciaux ce n'est plus un fruit
défendu les dunes de ghadamès au sud de
tripoli faisait rêver les amoureux du
désert
elles sont désormais accessibles aux
touristes la libye s'ouvre il on vient
même d'amérique pour la visiter il faut
voir aucune autre vie
les deux états auraient établi des
relations diplomatiques il ya tout juste
un an le pays du colonel kadhafi ne fait
plus peur la libye est un lieu sûr plus
sûr que certains endroits aux états unis
mais on est en sécurité e-mails et
exemple
il faut sept heures par la route pour
venir de tripoli le site de ghadamès aux
portes d'un océan de dunes semble promis
à un bel avenir
d'autant qu'il a un autre trésor à
offrir tout proche de l'as l'oasis une
étape sur la route des caravanes une
étrange cité admis troglodytes façonné
par quatre mille ans d'histoire ici il
n'ya pas de rue les toits ses touches
c'est ainsi que les femmes allaient
d'une maison à l'autre - med le guide
oubliera de nous préciser qu'en fait
elle n'avait pas le droit de croiser les
hommes et les femmes qu'on voyait les
terrasses
parce que les femmes toujours se
trouvera les ferrasse parce que les
maisons mais aide également être son
projet sont collés en bas le long des
ruelles couverte et fraîche les portes
d'entrée des maisons confort sommaire
mais toutes sont décorés depuis vingt
ans les 7000 habitants vivent dans des
immeubles neufs ils sont restés
propriétaires de leur ancienne demeure à
condition de l'ouvrir aux visiteurs les
touristes de toutes nationalités
beaucoup d'italiens mais également des
français et on a un petit avantage en
tant que français de reconnaissance et
d'amitié spécifique des bonnes images
oued majeure des français
le tourisme en plein essor bouleverse la
vie locale
cet instituteur a pu construire une
vaste maison parce qu'ils louent le
rez-de-chaussée aux voyageurs ses
revenus ont doublé
comme tant d'autres il rêve maintenant
d'opérations immobilières
pour l'instant je compte sur moi même je
vais je cherche des partenaires pour
créer un complexe hôtelier
si dieu le veut c'est mon rêve monter un
projet comme ça
à ghadamès ont construit le premier
établissement de luxe la banque
nationale affiche le portrait de
mouammar kadhafi avec toi ensemble
jusqu'à l'infini dit le slogan un infini
que beaucoup ici imagine constellé
d'étoilés celles des hôtels